Igor welcome back to St Louis welcome to
the studio three draws so far but all
fighting draws tell us about the
tournament so far for you thank you
sarid Ross and one one was in the
completely winning position yes
disappointed
so so many Iranian opportunities
well there is one straight way is easy
but when uh you need to choose
from 10 ways it's a very hard to
find them
I got into did not against the military
and that was a big one yeah how do you
recover psychologically from those type
of difficult moments not not so easy but
okay it's a life of a professional chess
player
every time you can blunder and you need
to recover so
I'm trying just to sleep
experience definitely helps for sure in
those difficult moments tell us a bit
about today's game it didn't feel like
any of you got any chances how was the
opening preparation did you feel like
you got anything quite quite uh quite
quiet a quiet game game yeah uh
Basics very interesting uh move uh
business yeah bb6 yeah what is the main
line in this position my main line is A6
or okay
even you see in the 95
yeah yeah but he played this move
basically yeah he played it quite fast
so it was definitely yeah very good
position from
bandariosk variation yes
and uh it seems like
around this time it was yeah
tell us about this position
I think that it's completely equal
completely equal and not a lot of things
have happened a lot of things have been
exchanged
do you welcome this result after those
topsy-turvy games that you had in the
previous rounds
to get something
but uh I I didn't prepare this
particular one
so I I Was preparing to the between
Equalization
but uh Gregory played it's so solid
always difficult against uh Gregory he's
such a tremendous competitor guys any
questions uh not for me just enjoying
the game and uh well uh keep going we
can keep going Igor absolutely
uh just remembering when I was playing